au centre-ville d'edmonton les dernières
traces du campement pki wind sont entrés
de disparaître les centaines de sans
abri qui s'y étaient établis sont
relogés dans le centre des congrès
converti refuse pour éviter qu'ils
pensent l'hiver sous la tente
mais un mois après son ouverture les 300
places ne suffisent pas certain soir de
tempête
après une décennie de diminution de
l'itinérance dans la capitale albertaine
la demande pour les services offerts aux
sans abri a explosé depuis le début de
la pandémie il a que vida porte en soi
son lot de défis
la pandémie a fragilisé ceux qui étaient
déjà les plus vulnérables
edmonton comme d'autres grandes villes
canadiennes a reçu des millions de
dollars du gouvernement fédéral pour
reloger cet hiver les sans abri qui
s'était construit des camps de fortune
sauf que lui un hôtel ou un centre de
conférence n'est qu'une solution
temporaire
un problème plus profond il manquerait
au canada 27 mille logements abordables
un problème que la pandémie ne permet
plus d'ignorer selon romain trust un
organisme qui coordonne les services de
lutte à l'itinérance est maintenant les
villes sont d'accord c'est pourquoi elle
réclame maintenant 7 milliards de
dollars du gouvernement fédéral pour
construire de nouvelles unités
une somme que des vaisseaux n'espère
retrouver dans la mise à jour économique
qui sera présentée le 10 par le
gouvernement trudeau
si la crise de l'itinérance n'est pas
nouvelle elle n'aura jamais été aussi
urgentes à régler ici mathieu gaye et
radio canada